in the long long long 20 30 year
existence or whatever you know like
future of that engine is that going to
be worth it obviously SpaceX said yeah I
think we can actually develop this this
Raptor engine
so it's just interesting to see the
things that have been looked at or even
reusability you know like the space
shuttle was reusable it was fully uh the
upper stage you know the shuttle itself
the Orbiter was you know I mean that
thing was for all intents and purposes a
reusable rocket
now did it live up to its expectations
not necessarily so it left a lot of bad
taste in people's mouth on the the ideas
of reusability so for SpaceX to kind of
come back into the room and on the table
and say we're going to use the reusable
rocket specifically we're going to do a
fully reasonable rocket you know a lot
of people are even still today a lot of
people going
yeah you're not gonna be able to do that
even today even today so like long term
you're not gonna be able to reuse a
scale
yeah but yeah definitely I think the
number of people that are saying that
today is is a small portion of those
that were saying that type of thing five
years ago you know when Elon did that
announcement in 2016
um for the its it was very very
aspirational and people were just like
yeah right you know and there's a large
number of people that had the factual
reasons to to think that and do that you
know at the time they'd only landed like
two Rockets or something you know when
they did that or maybe three it was a
very small number uh when they announced
that actually they had just lost a
couple months prior they just lost mo6
so they like they were still this young
blossoming company and they come in and
be like we figured out reusability and
now we're gonna go full scale and make
the world's biggest most heaviest most
powerful rocket ever and we're going to
fully reuse it and it's going to go to
Mars was just
pretty out there like it really was and
yeah you know it's all about perspective
but now again we're coming up on 100
consecutive Landings of an orbital class
rocket that's you know 45 meters tall
3.7 meters wide like this thing is huge
weighs 20 metric tons even empty when
it's Landing
that thing's already huge so seeing the
success of that I think people are now
more like well okay maybe maybe there is
actually
the opportunity to be fully reusable
that's definitely probably the biggest
constraint that I think has been
questioned that is yep